remember your favorite football shaped
cartoon from the 90s well this is craig
bartlett the non football shaped creator
per pay arnold so we thought we'd ask
him a few things about the show but
before we start craig can you do what
you do best
so told me to just start drawing arnold
we sure do when I designed Arnold in the
first place
I was really trying to make him stand
out I remember what Matt granny told me
he said you should try to make them so
that they work in silhouette or really
small on the screen so that's how it
started I was a little clay you know
football shaped head because it was
funny it was just me trying to be a
radical
[Applause]
piñon man has a pet peeve of mine in one
episode arnold meets the lonely pigeon
man and at the end of the episode go
somewhere i could live in peace with my
friends well the internet had some ideas
about that somebody said it's a suicide
story that he jumps off to the building
and Arnold in his mind to make sense out
of it imagines it a flew away I hate
that then we wrote in what we wrote
because I wanted him to fly away I
always imagined pigeon man going to
Paris next where he helps pigeons in
Paris I just really want to set the
record straight pigeon man is not a
suicide story he's fine I wanted to make
Harold have a really detailed specific
vibe of a city that was kind of ugly but
beautiful arnold city is based on where
i grew up in seattle and also where i
went to art school in Portland but it's
also based on Brooklyn with all the
Stoops and the brownstone
so it's really a kind of a collage of of
several northern cities when people talk
about what they like best about the show
the room comes up over and over again
which is a super cool attic with the
skylight and then he can climb right up
the stairs on the wall and and open the
window of his skylight and go down the
fire escape and we were reading Gabriel
Garcia Marquez and One Hundred Years of
Solitude and I love in the Time of
Cholera those were big influences on us
because magic realism is the term coined
about Garcia Marquez's writing I wanted
there to be a magical realism to Arnold
house and his neighborhood
[Music]
so Craig one last question
you got after all those years making TV
for kids was worth it making TV is
incredibly powerful you know having
millions of people watch what you make
on TV you realize what you say
especially to a kid they're going to
soak that up and they're never going to
forget it one of the themes of the
series is that you know you're kind of
you're kind of trying to make the most
out of a not-so-good situation that's
really what the shows about
I'll get these really heartfelt notes
from people and they'll say that they
got strengths and when things look their
worst what could be better than that
absolutely incredibly gratifying
[Music]